hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer and provides
content for you and aspiring software
engineers and today we are talking about
all the things coding bootcamp taught
me speaking of coding bootcamps i would
like to thank flatiron school for
sponsoring this video i actually went to
flat iron school
two
years ago a year and a half ago and i
am
i'm in love with everything that came
out of it but we'll get more into that a
little later so first yeah there's a lot
that going to a coding bootcamp will
teach you and so let's get
into it number one and it's so funny
because when i
when people said this to me i very much
rolled my eyes i was like okay but
number one is and this is truly like the
biggest one coding bootcamp taught me
how to learn
and i know how this sounds i know you
can stop rolling your eyes at this but
it's insane when you think about
i think it's because i'm on this side of
it now where i am an employed developer
and i
get it now
but you are constantly learning on the
job and especially when you are learning
a whole new language i learned
four different languages frameworks
while at flatiron school and that was in
15 weeks and so when you think about
that you learn how to learn quickly
you learn how to pick up different
languages and different
functions and scripts and
frameworks rapidly quick because you had
to do that during coding boot camp and
now you're in a new job and it is
probably like your biggest skill for my
job i needed to know python guess how
long it took me to learn python pause
the video put it in the comments i'm
serious like let's let this be a
discussion a fun little game put it in
the comments below
pause
okay
it took me
a solid
30 minutes now because i knew these
other languages when i was faced with a
coding problem or coding task i knew
exactly how i would solve it but i just
didn't know the specific syntax but i
knew oh i want to put an if statement
here and i want to then put a for loop
here um and whatnot and so all i needed
to do was look up how to create an if
statement in python then boom there was
how to create a for loop in python and
then boom there it was going to
occurring bootcamp just teaches you how
to learn like no other so that is
something i am extremely extremely
grateful for so that's one number two
going to a coding bootcamp taught me how
to approach a problem
so that i can solve it as efficiently
and quickly as possible when i say a
problem i mean quite literally like a
coding task so let's say you're creating
an app where users want to add things to
their shopping carts and so now you need
to figure out how to create functions so
that when they click on add to cart the
item that they're looking at gets added
to their cart and you know stays there
and they can re-access it later and
whatnot
going to recording bootcamp taught me
how exactly to approach the problem and
so let me give you an example
this sounds like a huge undertaking like
oh my goodness how am i going to add
something to a cart and then i let it
stay there and it's
like it sounds like a whole thing so i
would get now when i'm working
everything my whiteboards are my where
are they like
i've i've moved um if you haven't
if you haven't been able to tell i moved
everything's everywhere so i can't show
you my whiteboard if you've seen other
videos you know i have multiple so
pre-boot camp i would just see that as
just such a big problem but then post
boot camp is like okay how can we
separate this into the smallest chunks
possible so that this big chunk is now
itty-bitty chunks and so i would say
okay so first the user needs to click
something that says add to cart and so
first you need to create a either a
button or a text that says add to cart
so that's number one second the program
needs to be able to see okay so when
they click on me do something and so
that means i need to create an on click
function so yeah on click do something
now three on click i want the item to be
added to their cart so i need to create
a database of their cart so that every
time they click it grabs that item and
puts it into the database four and so
you end up being able to
just
see things in just such a different
light where something that seemed so
huge and enormous before now is so
possible through these little chunks
like i just integrated some
authentication for the company i'm
working for dreamworks for a web app
i've been working on and oh my goodness
i've never done anything like that
before but i was able to see it in a new
light because of the skills um that yeah
coding bootcamp provided me so that's
number number three
this is something that so many people i
think
i just have the wrong idea about
coding is not a solo sport
at all
at all now before you get at me like
okay well my cousin timothy over here
does
all the coding by himself he's a solo
programmer he's the only programmer on
his entire team in the entire company
and so what do you talk about he he does
it solo it is a solo sport
um actually
if you ask timothy um to pull up his
search history you will see likely
lots and lots of searches for the coding
and the functions and the problems he is
trying to solve because there's such an
amazing community of developers just out
there in the world
that so many problems that you run into
as a coder somebody has the solution you
are not likely you are not the first
person to run into this problem somebody
out there has the solution and so it is
still a team sport even if the team
isn't right there with you even if
you're not talking speaking with the
team one on one it is still very much a
team support when i attended and
enrolled in flattering school i was so
overwhelmed in a good way of the
community i was immediately
part of let me set this thing for you
just
women and men from all different
backgrounds both professionally and
personally and demographically
looking to do an amazing thing
become a software engineer
in a solid 15 weeks
now if that doesn't get y'all close
i don't know what will because oh my
goodness the respect we had for one
another for one taking this huge step
for being brave enough to pursue
something like this and also for just
being in the thick of it and we just
wanted nothing but the best for one
another and so that's really where it
seeped in like wow yeah no coding the
what the movies
say with the one person with the ten
screens just coding along and he is just
in his own bubble and doesn't talk to
anybody and he is just like this
introvert and whatnot
it is
usually not true
at all flyer school provided me this
community of future software engineers
looking to do nothing but succeed in
their career transition and i'm so so
grateful for that along with that in
general even though that's a big chunk
of um what i credit my success to you're
provided so much guidance and just
what's the word like i have this like
visual of like someone just like leading
someone like down a path and you just
like going through it of course you know
it's not as magical and beautiful when
you're in it because it is a lot you're
trying to do like i said a huge thing in
a short amount of time but the amount of
guidance they give you the amount of
instruction the amount of attention they
give you is truly insane and so if you
have been thinking about attending a
coding bootcamp flatiron school may be
the one for you as a student it was very
clear to me that their number one goal
was to get me hired get me hired because
that's that's the whole point of them
and i very much felt that from the very
first day of lessons to all the way in
my job hunt it definitely is a time and
monetary investment but oh my goodness
like take it from me y'all i had 50 in
my bank account before i
enrolled in flatter school i've actually
mentioned this in other videos i'm being
truly so serious with you and then 15
weeks after i enrolled i received my
very first job offer and then by the end
of that month of october which is when i
graduated by the end of that month here
i was signing my six figure job offer
and so it is just so crazy how quickly
you can go from one situation to the
next and now is a great time to do that
we've all been given this new start i've
been feeling great i've been if you
follow me on instagram you know the like
energy i've been on lately i've been
feeling so amazing because i just feel
that 2022 is just the year where we are
going to grow we are going to level up
we are going to pursue everything that
we have set on to pursue and we are
going to do the thing you know we're
gonna we're gonna go and so check out
the link in my description box below to
apply if you're not ready to apply it
and you want to still see what type of
career paths you can go through flatter
school is actually offering free lessons
in their different courses because they
don't just have software engineering
they have software engineering yes you
can go on the path to become a data
scientist you can go the cyber security
route or the product design route so
there's a different path for the
different interests you have and so if
you don't know what that is yet or you
kind of know but you want to test the
waters check out the free lessons the
link is in my description box so
definitely definitely check that out and
see what all 20 20 can do for you and
the very last thing that chloe's coding
bootcamp taught me is
cody is much more creative
than you think i've heard people talk
about oh you must have this analytical
mind and this like oh my goodness like
math math and all of this
i'm not gonna say they're wrong i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say that
i'm just saying there's so much beauty
and creativity in code that
more people need to talk about
because
you
it's so weird to think about because i
know i'm talking about you know a
computer and software you know how with
painting you can kind of just go
freehand and you kind of have an idea of
how you want it to go but not really and
so you're just like letting
you know the brush and everything lead
you and you're just like in that moment
honestly honestly a lot of times that's
how coding for me that's what it feels
like it's like okay so i know what i
want the end result to be but i don't
know how exactly to get there and so i'm
just going to keep trying a bunch of
things out and just find the beauty and
all the different solutions um possible
because there are so many different
solutions possible in just a regular one
assignment or code or problem and that
process is just such a beautiful process
especially and this will sound weird but
especially when things don't work out
and you're now
challenged to find a different
approach it's there
that the magic happens where you thought
you had it down and now you see it just
not gonna work out and so you must find
some other way to get put everything
together to get that final product
and then it works oh my goodness you
feel like an artist you feel you feel so
great um as you can see i really love my
job y'all i i really do um so yeah
there's just so much that this journey
can teach you and i'm just so excited
for you to see all these things for
yourself and have your own takeaways and
so check out flatiron school again the
link is in my description box below yeah
let's make 2022 be the year where we're
just so in love with our lives and our
careers and just every aspect of our
lives planner school can definitely help
you do that so yeah thanks y'all i'll
talk to you later bye